[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour ce nouveau club de la presse
rendez vous mensuel avec les médias
elvinois aujourd'hui radio sensations
avec nicolas kirillovitch marmite fm
avec nouradine agne et 7,8 actu les
nouvelles avec alexandre marqué bonjour
messieurs bonjour quelques-uns des
sujets et qui vont nous intéresser en ce
mois de juin le sommaire 20 et 27 juin
nous nous rendront aux urnes pour les
scrutins départementaux et régionaux
dans les yvelines la majorité sortante
de droite et du centre détient
l'intégralité des sièges et pourrait
bien réaliser à nouveau un grand chelem
mais y at il encore un véritable enjeu
est la radio fête ses 100 ans mais les
radios libres noms tels que 40 ans le
département à participer à cette
histoire l'occasion d'en parler
justement et d'écouter quelques
témoignages
et puis dans trois ans la france
accueillera les jeux olympiques saint
quentin en yvelines versailles à
l'honneur et pour faire monter
l'engouement parmi la population les
acteurs locaux comptent bien sur la
prochaine journée olympique qui se
déroulera le 23 juin
et puis comme chaque mois les
personnalités qui ont marqué l'actualité
blinoise à découvrir en fin d'émission
l'actualité en ce mois de juin c'est
bien évidemment les élections régionales
et départementales de scrutin important
pour le quotidien des français et
pourtant la participation ne devrait pas
être bien élevé la faute au contexte
sanitaire au désamour générale envers la
politique mais aussi est de la confusion
qui règne autour de ces élections votre
part liste par binôme ou encore quelles
compétences pour quelle institution pour
débuter la discussion sur ce sujet
pensez vous les uns et les autres que
nous médias ne vont peut-être pas assez
pédagogie à passer des explications sur
ces élections a commencé avec vous
nicolas sap est peut-être une critique
qu'on peut faire aux médias mais je
pense qu'en fait les journalistes sont
un peu comme les comme les citoyens ils
sont un peu parfois perdus quand
les accords qui peuvent être passés aux
niveaux régionaux qu'ils ne sont pas au
niveau départementaux c'est on a du mal
à y comprendre il voir vraiment vraiment
pierre qu'est ce qu'il en est après on
essaie de faire notre possible mais je
crois qu'en fait on ne peut pas on peut
pas rendre clair quelque chose qui ne
l'est pas de base on n'a pas ce pouvoir
ce pouvoir en août donc on essaie de
faire un maximum mais non on ne peut pas
inventer quelque chose qui est qu'il ne
l'est pas et donc voila vous le disiez
l'abstention est ce que j avais deux
plus importantes qu'en 2015 je crois
qu'en 2015 pour les départementales
c'était 55% dans les villes
à l'époque ce n'était pas couplée écrire
- donc mais moi je ne sais pas moi je
fais je fais le pari quand même qu'il y
aura mon abstention cette fois ci parce
que le couplage régionale départementale
va je pense à inciter des gens quand
même à se déplacer et puis après un plus
d'un an que vivent les gens vont avoir
quand même envie de donner leur avis
donc on va pas voter pour vraiment les
départementales et les régionales on va
voter un peu sur la gestion de la crise
je pense par le gouvernement un premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle avant
2000 2022 en fait alexandre vous avez le
sentiment d'arriver à d'arriver à
couvrir cette campagne comment ça
s'organise du côté 7,8 actuelle est
nouvelle mais comme disait nicolas on
essaie de faire le maximum on aussi mais
effectivement donc on a couvert tous les
candidats notamment des régionales son
nid dans les yvelines et un bayou
pécresse les autres pour les
départementales bas on essaie de faire
les candidats sur nous donne mais c'est
vrai que bon on le voit bien sur le web
encore jamais un sujet sur le web sur
les cantonales sont les départementales
sur les régionales bat pendant sa marche
pas qu'on a beau on a beau le faire on a
beau ciel d'être pédagogue et d'en
parler on voit bien que ça intéresse pas
toujours moins qu'un fait divers ou
d'autres sujets malheureusement à ce
mélange des scrutins régional
départemental les deux élections son
couple et on va écouter à ce propos
pierre bédier c'est le président sortant
du département des yvelines il est
candidat à un nouveau mandat il était
l'invité récemment de patrice carmouze
sur tv 78 je soutiens moi même la liste
de valérie pécresse ce qui n'est pas le
cas effectivement de tous ceux qui sont
candidats sous les couverts d'ensemble
pour les yvelines en réalité monsieur
hollande
lorsqu'il a décidé de faire les
élections départementales et régionales
le même jour s'est trompé car les
émissions et les différences régionales
sont d'une autre nature les élections
régionales surtout en faisons c'est très
grande région il ya désormais penser que
la région aquitaine l'argent nouvelle
aquitaine et à une superficie
équivalente à celle de l'autriche
c'est à dire à un et ça crée pas un des
petits de l'union européenne et donc
c'est en fait que le prémice d'élections
nationales l'élection régionale élue
voilà les débats sont beaucoup plus
politique au sens partisan
alors que vraiment nous dans les
yvelines nos débats départementaux sont
parfois pour ceux qui ne s'intéressent
pas la gestion locale sans doute un peu
rébarbatif
ou est ce qu'on met un collège faut-il
faire ou ne pas faire une route ont fait
pas la révolution
on va se concentrer sur ce scrutin
départemental justement le département
qui gère les collèges les routes le rsa
aussi par exemple et depuis à 2015 nous
votons pour des binômes une femme un
homme et pour les yvelines il y à 21
cantons donc 42 sièges
voilà pour les explications rapides 21
cantons avec des découpages qui sont
parfois très compliqué ça ne simplifie
pas le scrutin nordine pour vous sur
cette départementale alors je sais que
du côté de marmites vous avez un pas
forcément couvert directement le scrutin
mais est-ce qu'un enjeu néanmoins et
puis on va venir la situation de trappe
du coup oui effectivement wilfredo on
couvre pas forcément on n'a pas
forcément les moyens de couvrir toutes
ces élections surtout quand elles soient
installés sur soi soit les yvelines sauf
sur la région mais on parle quand même
des départements des départementales on
parle de l'importance du département
l'essai de décrypter un petit peu les
compétences et départementales et
régionales
et si vous permettez juste une petite
petite remarque
contrairement à ce que disait nicolas
moi je pense que l'abstention va être
très forte
moi c'est ce que j'ai ressenti sur le
terrain surtout avec le déconfinement
s'il fait beau alors on va pas
caricaturer à non plus les citoyennes et
citoyens français mais s'il fait beau la
après le thé confinement des gens ont
envie de bouger envie de prendre le
soleil envie de sortir de changer les
idées ici aussi s'il plus ils resteront
chez eux
il ya les deux scrutins en un mois j'ai
échangé avec des saint quentinois qui
savait même pas qu'il y avait deux
scrutins en ans qui avait pas compris en
tout cas ton voter et pour les
départementales et et pour les époux
relais pour les régionales donc c'est
assez compliqué et puis reste aussi
troisième élément toujours la peur
d'aller dans un bureau de vote pour
certains qui ont encore peur du coc vide
donc ça c'est aussi un élément qui est
important qui va faire que ça va être
compliqué et puis pierre bédier ont
vertement entendre il a je pense qu'il a
raison d'en élire les conseillers
départementaux fait un petit tour de
réseau lancé comme ça dans le public des
noms de conseillers régionaux des nôtres
conseillers départementaux vous allez
voir ça va pas faire ça va vous n'avez
pas avoir beaucoup de beaucoup de gens
qui connaissent elles ces personnes et
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
après sur le sur le canton commençant le
canton de trappes pardon ou plus
globalisé justement pourra parler d'aidé
ont justement alors le contrat parce que
je le redis il ya eu un grand chelem la
dernière fois en 2015 de la part de la
droite est et du centre grand chelem qui
pourrait une nouvelle fois se produire
donc les listes majoritaires sous
l'étiquette épi ensemble pour les
yvelines cette partie qui a été fondée
par la majorité
là sous l'égide de pierre bédier par
contre un canton éventuellement qui
pourrait repasser à gauche c'est celui
de trappe alors trappe qui aujourd'hui
dans le découpage comporte la ville de
trappes la ville d'elancourt et la ville
de la verrière voilà et ce depuis 2015
avant 2015 c'était uniquement la ville
de trappes et c'était un canton qui
était à gauche 2015 nouveau découpage le
canton a basculé à droite dans votre
avis nadine ce qu'on tombe sur trappe
peut rester à droite pourrait basculer
où ça va être compliqué toute façon on
l'a dit un tout va si tout va être liée
également à l'abstention je pense que le
duo anne marie bouquet et à ali rabais
donc divers gauche vont avoir comme
challenge roccat comme défi de voter
massivement sur la ville de trappes 6
arrive à faire ça effectivement peut
être que le canton peut basculer les
attentions
du côté de la verrière même si d'aucuns
considèrent que la verrière est tombé à
cause de l'abus de la division de la
gauche
le maire nicolas de la ville pourra
quand même surfer sur cette victoire aux
municipales pour peut-être apporter des
voix avec les voix d'elancourt qui
votent majoritairement pour l'instant
tout cas à droite et garder ce sont
contents tout casser c'est très ouvert
sur le canton de prades contrairement à
d'autres cantons dans l'est
vidéo parce que donc il ya cinq listes
sur ce canton de trappes la liste
sortante c'est celle de nicolas
dainville et dan capio qui remplace jean
michel fourgous et anne-k piot en 2015
nicolas dainville avait succédé à jean
michel fourgous en cours de mandat
puisqu'il avait démissionné pour prendre
la présidence de l'agglomération voilà
pour la la tambouille l'organisation
politique pour être un petit peu clairs
là dessus qu'on nous reproche pas ce
manque de pédagogie et d'explication en
tout cas et puis de l'autre côté pour
pour la droite c'est effectivement pour
la gauche pardon vous l'avez dit donc le
maire de trappes qui lui qui lui se
présente pour vous et nicolas l'enjeu
sur ces élections dont les yvelines se
situe au est ce qu'il faut regarder
particulièrement attraper ce qu il yad
autres cantons aussi intéressant on
pourra évoquer la situation du
rassemblement national on va y venir
aussi tout à l'heure on va justement
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'allais vous
dira alors si on parle de la gauche plus
précisément il ya aussi le peut-être le
canton de montigny le bretonneux même si
la surprise ne se passera plus des plus
compliqués à réaliser pour pour la
gauche mais là aussi la gauche part unie
avec notamment en sortant le maire de
guyancourt sinon oui ça ça risque de se
passer du côté du du mantois où le
rassemblement national notamment parce
que les enjeux sécuritaires on le voit
bien d'un point de vue national
apprennent plus en plus le pas sur sur
l'actualité et peut-être que le et
rennes pourrait surfer sur 7 sur cette
actualité nationale et en aucun cas
locale puisque les compétences
sécuritaire du département et des
régions est quasiment nul
à part dans les transports pour la
région mais il pourrait ainsi surfer sur
sur l'actualité nationale pour remporter
pourquoi pas un canton dans dans le
mantois çà çà çà c'est possible et
notamment face à pierre bédier et dans
ce cas là ce serait pour eux pays comme
vous le disiez un échec puisque ils ont
fait 21 sur 21 il ya six ans ils font 20
sur 21 aux 19 sur 21
même s'ils auront une majorité plus que
large ça pourrait être vu comme il ya eu
un échec pour eux alexandre à présent
sur les enjeux de ce scrutin dans les
yvelines
oui l'enjeu n'est pas de savoir si la
majorité départementale va à la tête du
département ça sent tous convaincus je
pense effectivement l'intérêt de savoir
si on va réussir à refaire le grand
chelem pas que comme les six ans
effectivement il ya trois cantons dans
le nord autour du mantois ou où le
rassemblement national espère jouer les
trouble-fête
donc c'est mantes la jolie où pierre
bédier président sortant affrontera
cyril août l'ancien maire de mantes la
ville le canton de libé et puis surtout
peut-être créé la surprise le canton de
venir sur scène ou hépatiques stéphanie
lr affrontera du coup deux anciens
l'adjoint de mantes la ville est aussi
pierre krasucki pour le pcf oms a fait
une affiche à un peu improbable et c'est
peut-être là où va jouer jouer ce grand
chelem ce que patrick stefanini et un
peu parachute et il arrive à 67 ans est
un réseau un homme car à très grand cd
un cv long comme le bras
mais françois fillon l'ancien préfet
mais mais mais inconnu sur sur le
secteur et face à lille va se retrouver
ça à deux anciens maires adjoints de
demain la ville est sur un secteur rural
où marine le pen arrivé en tête lors des
présidentielles
donc je pense fort à mon style ce canton
contraire ces cantons plus
particulièrement c'est laurent morin le
responsable du rassemblement national
dans les yvelines qui est qui et
candidats notamment sur sur bonnieure
donc nouradine vous souhaitez intervenir
oui juste une petite remorque qui vous
permettez wilfried par rapport à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur la
responsabilité
voilà notamment peut-être des
journalistes même si sur les yvelines
c'est vrai que bon à moins d'une grosse
surprise la majorité devraient rester du
côté de le pays
mais je pense qu'il est important de ne
pas laisser penser peut-être aux
téléspectateurs que l'élection serait
déjà joué et que en gros c'est pas la
peine d'aller voter non pas que je suis
reste immobile influence médiatique sur
la décision des électeurs d'aller voter
ou non mais quand même certains
pourraient dire que cette élection ne
changera rien puisque la majorité en
place va l'emporter largement
donc au contraire je pense que c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire lorsqu'on
contraire fouet insisté sur les
différences entre les différentes
candidatures les différents projets qui
sont partis sur le département
et voilà essayé de beaucoup de pédagogie
sur cela voilà c'était juste la petite
remarque que je voulais et je voudrais
moi aussi peut-être insisté sur un point
si on mettait en avant le rôle des
médias est peut-être des journalistes
locaux qui n'est pas suffisant danser
dans cette campagne
mais en fait il faut éclaire aussi les
candidats ne font pas une énorme
campagne du fait du contexte sanitaire
mais tellement et n'ont pas envie au ski
et notamment la majorité sortante de
faire campagne parce qu'on sait que la
prime et aux sortants généralement dans
ces élections on a du mal vous savez tv
70 puisqu'on travaille un peu sur
élections en binôme on a du mal à
contacter les équipes d et des candidats
on a du mal à avoir des rendez-vous des
interviews donc il ya ça aussi qui joue
c'est que les candidats eux mêmes ne
joue pas trop le jeu c'est plus la
campagne des régionales ont par contre
les candidats aux régionales se
manifeste alors on va pas rentrer dans
le détail des enjeux mais effectivement
il faudra regarder aussi on parlait du
premier tour de la présidentielle les
régionales pour le coup ça en est un bon
exemple
je reviens juste sur le rassemblement
national on va écouter à présent laurent
morin délégué départemental donc dû rn78
il est candidat sur le canton et de
bonnières il évoque les enjeux pour son
parti de manière générale la région ile
de france et le département des yvelines
sont quand même un territoire
électoralement compliqué pour nous ceci
dit
l'accélération de la recomposition
politique les ralliements que nous
enregistrons la pertinence de nos
constats et de nos solutions dans
certains cantons des yvelines notamment
mantes la jolie mais bonnière les
mureaux et rambouillet où nous sommes
particulièrement fort en 2015 sur ces
cantons là nous faisions pratiquement
40%
je pense que nous pouvons envisager la
victoire sur ces cantons canton le
canton de bonnières donc nous présente
laurent - et je reprécise parce qu'on
ait évoqué tout à l'heure le canton de
menthe de le canton pierre bédier
justement donc face à lui est cyril
notre l'ancien maire de mantes la ville
est également en binôme mathilde andraud
inquiéter les européennes et l'ancien
responsable du département effectivement
le rassemblement national qui met toutes
ses forces dans la bataille
est ce que pour pour conclure sur ce
sujet des élections et puis nous en
reparlerons après le scrutin fin juin
est-ce qu'on va assister peut-être une
recomposition de la droite
est ce que ça peut jouer aussi parce que
le rassemblement national on l'a vu au
niveau national au niveau des régions
fait un appel du pied essaye de bâtir
des ponts de large au pont de grandes
structures avec la lrs qui aura une
recomposition aussi de la droite par la
suite vous imaginez dans les yvelines
qui se lancent alors si je dis bien
personne ne veut prendre la parole des
jeunes nicolas réside dans les yvelines
j'ai pas l'impression j'ai un peu j'ai
l'impression que la digue est quand même
assez assez solide entre le
rassemblement national et la droite et
le centre en général puis cet accord un
peu unique un finalement dans les
yvelines où ou le ensemble pour les
yvelines la droite quand même englobe
une bonne partie du centre on n'y a pas
il n'ya pas il n'ya pas visiblement de
deux ponts qu'existe et puis on voit
bien laurent morin il y ait comme car
bédié ils se tapent dessus très durement
excusez-moi l'expression mais dans les
médias ou même en off quand on parle
avec eux ils ont même pas des mots très
tendres on a du mal à imaginer une
alliance une recomposition et même dans
les personnages politiques principaux de
la droite yvelinoise il n'y a pas de ya
pas de discours on va dire bienveillant
envers le rassemblement national donc si
ça peut se passer au national ce genre
d'accords ou de liens qui se créent
j'ai du mal à l'imaginer dans les
yvelines oui les yvelines sont
historiquement une une terre
centre-droit depuis toujours un endroit
où l'extrême-droite et des résultats
assez faible généralement remis du coup
dans le nord du département vers mantes
et aussi vers rambouillet dans le sud
est
je pense que la droite et le centre ont
pas besoin comme ça peut être le cas par
un peu en paca du rassemblement national
pour se faire élire je pense que ça joue
et puis il fait aussi effectivement que
pierre bédier soit en opposition avec
cyril moulin vente
je pense que ça ne savait pas non plus
le rapprochement faudra voir ce que font
les électeurs aussi un risque car une
influence du national une partie des
électeurs et l'eire qui peuvent partir
vers le rassemblement national la
question de la sécurité est omniprésente
et aussi dans le département des
yvelines on se souvient malheureusement
aussi des attentats qui ont touché du
côté de rambouillet l'ailé les forces et
les forces de l'ordre
tout ça peut avoir aussi une incidence
mais on va pas projeter non plus on
verra bien les résultats s'ils allaient
y aura un autre intérêt je pense qu'on a
commencé à parler que quand on attrape
c'est les résultats des nouveaux maires
ont été élus il ya une petite année
c'est le cas de geoffroy bac de keating
qui se présente donc mr du
perray-en-yvelines qui se présente sur
le canton de rambouillet il sera
intéressant de voir son résultat un an
après son élection
et puis bien sûr le canton une trappe ou
deux nouveaux maires se présente donc
nicolas dainville conseiller
départemental sortant et maire de la
verrière et qui fait face à un
mécontentement d'une partie de du bois
de l'étang saint nombreux projets de
démolition
et puis elle ira b maire de trappes et
dont l'élection à été annulée par le
ministre hâtif en février dernier et qui
a fait appel devant le conseil d'état
ça sera intéressant de voir voir leurs
résultats
aussi ce que décide le conseil d'état
l'annulation pas et inéligibilité pour
ali rabais qui pourrait éventuellement
devenir conseiller départemental là ce
sera encore autre chose on va s'arrêter
là avec la politique scrutin 20 et 27
juin à la fois pour les départementales
et pour les régionales et donc on quitte
la politique on va parler et radio à
présent
22 décembre 1921 radio tour eiffel
première station créée en france et met
pour la première fois depuis paris
depuis la tour eiffel donc s'entend
après une semaine de célébrations pour
marquer cet anniversaire la semaine
s'achève tout juste début juin elle
s'est même un double anniversaire pour
2021 le 9 novembre 1981 françois
mitterrand autorisé par dérogation la
fin il prononçait la fin du monopole
d'état pour les radios locales privées
associatives ce sont donc les 40 ans de
la radio libre en france nous avons deux
journalistes de radio radio associative
aujourd'hui que ce soit nicolas
kirillovitch on aura dit nein pour
marmite et pour sensations ça représente
quoi cet anniversaire pour vous si on
dit rien du tout s'amorce plaisance a
quand même donné la possibilité aussi
alors d'avoir une parole email j'espère
que c'est pas rien du tout oui c'est
vrai que c'est une date importante et
qu'on a aussi célébré du côté de
marmites et fun et même si en ce moment
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à moi
j'espère que nicolas va pas mal de
prendre
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à beaucoup m
de l'image avec la radio et que pour moi
la enfin au nicolas pour sensations je
ne comprends pas nicolas titre personnel
parce que non mais pas d'image avec la
radio mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai
toujours aimé ce côté un peu mystérieux
de la voix j'ai toujours été déçu de
voir les visages des voix que
j'entendais à la radio
non pas qu'il ya un effet un peu qui
secoue la voilà une superbe voix et puis
après quand on voit la personne et des
succès physique de radio josé josé pas
vous le dire voilà ça mais ça peut
s'appeler et du coup c'est vrai que tout
cet imaginaire ce côté descriptive après
la voit aussi le timbre de la voix
voilà moi je pense que c'est ça qui qui
a toujours fasciné qui a toujours plus
dans la radio même si de plus en plus il
ya des radios qui met quand même l'image
et qui montre un petit peu leurs
animateurs leur animatrice
mais voilà je pense que c'est une date
importante il ya beaucoup qui disait un
jeu l'entente des samoa déjà il ya une
dizaine quinzaine d'années que la radio
est un
mais déjà pour les anciens que la radio
allait disparaître et avec cette crise
la crise sanitaire qu'on a connu il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui écoutent
la radio et qui veulent aussi s'éloigner
de tout ce flou d'image pour la que ce
soit avec les smartphones avec la télé
avec les tablettes et voilà du coup
c'est un bel anniversaire et puis m
alors nous on a fait plusieurs choses
sur le mythe fm du coup on a célébré ses
100 ans qui coïncidait aussi avec la
semaine de la radio sensations fêter
également voilà avec des chroniques
originale mais qui faisait le lien entre
l'art le rap et la radio le sport et la
radio l'importance de la radio dans la
seconde guerre mondiale on a même eu à
l'invité du radio club de saint quentin
et flic qui est venu nous parler de la
radio côté technique donc voilà tout ça
a été passionnant
donc voilà je vais pas monopoliser la
parole mais vraiment la radio reste un
essai sentant le problème la radio reste
quand même un média en média important
on peut faire un peu d'histoire juste
nicolas avant de vous passer aussi la
parole parce que le département des
yvelines a pris une part importante au
moment de l'explosion des radios pirates
à l'époque ensuite radios libres donc à
partir de 81
la première radio dans les yvelines a
été créé en 79 c'était aux mureaux radio
vexin val de seine et elle existe
toujours il y en a eu d'autres après
hervé euradio vieille église du côté de
rambouillet et qui existe toujours
également il ya radio triangle aussi
anciennement radio triangle aujourd'hui
radio sensations
nicolas d'ailleurs j'ai une question
pour vous savez pourquoi radio triangle
jeu parce que je crois que les premiers
locaux de radio triangle il était dans
un bâtiment en forme de triangle est les
fenêtres étaient en forme de triangle
c'était là la mjc le clc du
mesnil-saint-denis à l'époque voilà
bravo
laissez vous piéger mais ses amis et
maîtrisent pas les 79 80 aujourd'hui qui
représente un peu cet anniversaire pour
vous des radios alors les radios qui
perdent un peu
malgré tout en tout cas pour les grandes
radios nationales d'auditeurs comment
vous vivez cet anniversaire
ben un peu un peu comme comme nouradine
enfin sur le rôle de la radio moi je
pense je salue je n'ai pas les chiffres
de tous de toutes les radios évidemment
d'un point de vue national mais je pense
que le rôle du média radio et est quand
même on lui prédisait effectivement des
années loin et je trouve qu'il renforce
et j'ai pas l'impression que que les
gens malgré effectivement les évolutions
technologiques et l'accès aujourd'hui à
tout ce qu'on peut avoir toutes les
plateformes et autres télés que les gens
écoutent beaucoup moins la radio et
notamment par avec avec la crise est
donc cet anniversaire il est important
parce que beaucoup de gens ont écouté au
moment de notamment de 80 l'explosion
des radios libres on écoute et on va
écouter la radio il ya eu je j'ai
l'impression un coup de mou des années
90 2000 avec l'explosion de la télé puis
l'arrivée des de toutes ces nouvelles
chaînes mais moi aujourd'hui j'ai pas
l'impression que la radio soit un média
démodés ou au contraire il s'est hissé
renforcer et nous aussi on a essayé de
fêter ses 100 ans un peu à notre manière
en faisant de nombreuses interviews et
des interviews de deux journalistes qui
ont connu des radios associatives des
radios locales qui assurent aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus exposés pour certains
d'entre eux puisqu'ils sont en radio
nationale ou à la télévision et
notamment bruno bruno guillon qui vit
dans l'est dans les yvelines animateur
radio est très connu et on a eu la
chance a rappelé aux sensations de
l'interviewer pour eux pour cette
semaine de spécial je pense qu'on peut
on peut l'écouter ce qui fait que ça se
passe bien en tout cas c'est quand tu
deviens à l'aise c'est à dire c'est plus
quand tu fais de la radio mais quand tu
es la radio voilà c'est à dire que quand
tu es au micro comme tes dents dans la
vie voilà aura dix ans radio au début je
jouais un rôle quoi tu vois que j'avais
j'avais un modèle que j'ai copié voilà
et après je me suis créé mon style et la
télé c'est pareil et la télé c'est plus
compliqué parce que comme je le disais
il ya l'image en vad mais voilà c'est ça
et que après un rapport avec ton
physique
vois tu vois j'ai fait de la radio
depuis tout petit où on me disait tu as
un vrai physique de radio sur deux
contres mais à la télé quand tu dois du
match il ya merde c'est pas dis donc
donc il faut s'apprivoiser et moi il m'a
fallu du temps et m'a fallu dix ans mais
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des chaînes
qui m'ont fait confiance puis surtout
d'avoir des gens qui sont dit tiens il
ya peut-être un truc quoi
télé qui est installé dans les yvelines
nicolas willot way pour éviter à votre
historique
peu de gens le savent mais à tous les
nouvelles on est plus tourné sur le
papier sur le web
mais à une époque justement 1981 hard on
avait une radio qui s'appelait donc cds
canal versailles stéréo je crois ouais
font des parents l'enfant qui était
directeur du journal par jonchère les
lignes qui était le fondateur du cirano
donc à l'époque avec des animateurs ont
commencé leur carrière l'axé devenu très
connu par la suite comme nicolas
poincaré pascale clark comme quoi comme
quoi la presse locale cela reste amen à
tout et puis à et puis il y aussi rfm
j'ai passé on vous en avait parlé aussi
on n'a pas parlé de rfm mais alors juste
avant de parler de rfm ce que vous avez
parlé de cvs donc canal versailles
stéréo dans les années 80 et qui avait
été lancée donc par le rolland fort vous
avez évoqué des grands noms du
journalisme qui sont passés par par vos
locaux au moment où existait cette radio
qui par la suite est parti dans les
hauts-de-seine et et s'est perdu à la
fréquence a été plus que revendus
jusqu'à disparaître
il y avait aussi un certain michel
laugier qui a fait ses débuts là-bas
michel ollivier ancien maire de montigny
le bretonneux aujourd'hui sénateur on
les écoute roland faure à cette époque
là a tout simplement créé un véritable
laboratoire d'idées et c'est comme ça
que ensuite quelques années plus tard
c'est à dire en 86 lorsqu'il a été nommé
à la présidence de radio france il a key
france info
petit clin d'oeil à michel logis
retrouver dans nos archives nous avions
traité ce sujet des radios au moment de
25e anniversaire donc c'était il ya
quelques années on peut parler d réfère
aussi à l'aise ici vous le souhaitez
alex regard m6 est né en pesant le
savent aussi je pense est né à vélizy 2
au sein du centre commercial lanthane
était sur le toit du centre et à
l'époque les îles avec coluche notamment
parmi les animateurs
donc ça a débuté au sein du centre
commercial et ça fait comme ça je crois
quatre cinq ans avant de partir vers la
défense en 1996 cette fréquence est
fondée par patrick meyer qui avait
annoncé cette radio et qui même pendant
tout un temps a été brouillée parce
qu'ils y diffuser de la publicité ça
c'était aussi interdit et l'antenne
était brouillée et devait bidouiller
leur émetteur avec coluche qui a animé à
son émission pendant les travaux
l'humour continue si j'ai bonne mémoire
dans les archives que j'ai pu consulter
nicolas vous voulez à réintervenir oui
je ne sais plus à quel propos mais je
voulais rebondir aussi sur ce qu'avait
dit nouradine concernant concernant la
vidéo et la raison moi aussi je partage
cet avis la radio c'est d'abord à un
timbre de voix et je crois que toutes
les radios qui se sont lancés
massivement dans la diffusion alors à
deux sensations à son échelle l'a fait
aussi mais je pense notamment aux radios
nationales dans la diffusion télé je
crois que c'est c'est pas une réussite
parce que les gens ne recherche pas sans
radio ils recherchent la proximité on
l'a dit avec cette crise aussi je pense
qu'il ya un besoin de deux ans un tueur
d'image au bout d'un moment et qui à ce
retour à la radio et la radio peu sur ce
point-là faire preuve de force et donc
je pense que c'est ça la radio la force
de la radio c'est la voix uniquement la
voix qui laisse aussi de faire
travailler l'imagination et popa ko paca
se perdent sur sur ce chemin là elle a
essayé quelques années notamment en
france info en allant sur la télé je
suis pas sûr que ça soit une réussite
que ce soit l'avenir de la radio parce
que l'avenir de la radio c'est de rester
tout simplement une radio sur les ondes
oui et puis rapidement vous le disais
tout à l'heure où il ferait d'y aller à
l'audience peut-être du national aussi
qui je suis un petit peu
après si on regarde vraiment l'audience
globale même si on rajoute ce qui est
sur internet c'est à dire les podcasts
que soient les podcasts des radios et
podcasts natif comme on dit c'est à dire
qu'ils sont créés pour internet
c'est vrai que les chiffres sont assez
impressionnants et qu'il ya de plus en
plus des couteaux si par ce biais là
même si certains pourraient dire comment
le podcast c'est sur l'autre chose est
en tout cas voilà l'audio globalement
fait vraiment est vraiment très
important oui c'est un mode de
consommation en tout cas d' écoute
différente ou comme pour la télé aussi
un qui aujourd'hui se consomme beaucoup
en replay sur des programmes spécifiques
sur le web aussi est juste pour conclure
on va rester sur marmite justement
marmite qui date du début des années
2000 qui a vu débuter aussi à des
animateurs qui aujourd'hui sont connus
nationalement je pense aïssa donc bien
écoutez le écoutez il ça c'était c'était
en 2005
on essaye de toucher un maximum de la
population trappe
donc on est serré mais carrément tous
les genres de musique
on a eu des retours il ya des personnes
qui disent qu' il aime bien justement
puisque il ya un mélange de plein de
genres de musique et les gens qui
n'écoutent pas forcément de la chanson
française il
il écoute quelques morceaux ils disent
ah tiens suis là et bien donc qui
commence à apprécier
donc on essaye de
bien faire ça pour que tous les gens
trappe après si bien cette radio et ça
donne bien issus de déclic théâtre qui
naturellement s'est retrouvé à l'antenne
de la radio et la quinzaine aura
nouradine qui sera le star nationale
c'est ça c'est ça je vais faire sur
tommy en voice est déjà sur les lego je
voyais que ça il ya contre l'amia qui
disent ah non ça c'est un copain qui
aime bien châtie bien
et en plus il est plus costaud que moi
dans la nord vous voyez qu'il a gagné en
aisance à depuis 2005 il était animateur
réalisateur et c'est vrai que son
parcours est apte est assez
impressionnant et voilà qu'on retrouve
et issa aussi au niveau national c'est
toujours quelque chose qui fait plaisir
voilà de voir que du local on peut pas
sur la saône à la praille anaky qui
veulent pas aller au national il y en a
qui sont très bien dans le local est qui
qui ont peut-être une posture un peu
plus militant pour une plus de proximité
et voilà en tout cas ça fait toujours
plaisir a effectivement de revoir ces
images avec chloé qu'on a parfois aussi
un wiki bisous avec le risque
voilà qui était à l'origine du projet de
marmites fm avec papy donc valu muselet
aussi également voilà bon anniversaire
donc aux radios on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler un dc d'ici la fin de l'année
2021 le vrai anniversaire les vrais 40
ans de la radio libre ce sera ce sera en
novembre 80 et d'ailleurs on peut
s'interroger sur cette semaine des
santons de la radio ce qu'est la vraie
première émission c'était décembre 1921
du côté de paris alors pour la bande fm
en tout cas bon anniversaire aux radios
passent aux personnalités à la une ces
mois ci
les choix des journalistes des
rédactions locales et on va rester
malgré tout un peu dans les radios avec
nicolas avec nous à dean tous les deux
ce mois-ci vous souhaitez vous
souhaitiez mettre à l'honneur les
bénévoles de ces radios associatives
nous a dit non et comment nicolas
comment balesi comme vous voulez bien la
personnalité du mois pour moi il sera
plurielle puisque sont tous les belges
croient que nicolas aussi à fait la même
chose c'est tous les bénévoles qui
depuis à 2001 font grandement vivre
marmite fn puisque près de 60% des
programmes sont faits par des bénévoles
des bénévoles saint quentinois alors de
la musique c'est à dire la chanson
française de jean-françois au reggae
ragga de domme de la poésie de maguy et
jean-yves au compte de mario monicault
des débats de société avec le trap yves
logghe radio de mehdi les expressions de
la langue française avec valérie alias
valve ou le bien-être avec fabienne de
yoga avec marilyn une émission de
musique d'une interview avec les maisons
de retraite et les ehpad avec nathalie
le sport avec gilles samyn et julien la
parentalité la maternité avec fanta les
lectures théâtralisées avec jacques
maggie et toute l'équipe de contrebande
c'est bientôt fini face evelyne avec
chloé la cité des métiers avec valérie
l'éducation aux médias avec cindy la
diététique la botanique la permaculture
la philosophie avec greg le rap avec
julien et robin ouanna donc merci à
toutes ces femmes et tous les hommes qui
est jeune vieux d'horizons différents
qui font marmite fm et puis on peut
rajouter aussi l'équipe qui les
encadrent c'est à dire la rédaction la
rédaction des marmites fmc moi tout seul
donc merci lointain depuis voilà des
petits pots si avec noémie ronan
géraldine sophie claire et naulleau
voilà et puis un clin d'oeil à chloé
qu'on a cité tout à l'air et à mains
nues
tous ces bénévoles qui font vivre les
radios forcément aujourd'hui si elle
existe encore c'est grave grâce à leur
engagement tout à fait nicolas oui c'est
ça moi et moi si c'était pareil c'était
un clin d'oeil à tous les bénévoles au
delà de radio sensations aussi ceux de
marmites fm et de toutes les radios
locales de
et associatifs de france parce que sans
elle qui comme le réseau associatif en
général dans le domaine du sport
culturelles ou autres sans les bénévoles
c'est impossible et encore plus
aujourd'hui où les financements se font
de plus en plus rare et donc il faut
compter sur la bonne volonté des gens
j'ai pas nécessairement autant de gens à
saluer moira de sensations parce que
vous savez aussi qu'une radio locale
céder aux débats aujourd'hui il ya un
peu moins d'émissions à radio sensations
qui sont faits par des bénévoles mais je
tenais à saluer quelqu'un que l'on
appelle franck david alias franck et
d'art qui un journaliste plutôt d'ordre
national mais qui est très engagé à
radio sensations qui d'un point de vue
éditorial clairement tient la radio
presque à lui tout seul qui est
journaliste à m6 et qui est aussi engagé
dans d'autres associations d'ailleurs
c'est l'occasion de de pinte clin d'oeil
donc c'est vraiment il est multi multi
fonctions franck est il engagé dans en
attend le combat d'un lange il est aussi
vice-président désormais de la maison
europe des yvelines est qui qui vient
quasiment toutes les semaines à la radio
pour partager son expérience avec les
salariés et damman moi personnellement
et puis avec les stagiaires sur place
qui forme qui l'aide à ceux à se former
il fait pas d'antenne à franck c'est
vraiment que d'un point de vue est dit
et à lille et il est derrière il est dit
conseil
il vous fait des commentaires sur votre
voix qui n'est jamais assez bonne et sur
vos papiers qui ne sont jamais passés
bond à ses yeux mais voilà c'est
important parce que sans lui par exemple
bas radio sensations aujourd'hui serait
probablement beaucoup moins pour moi sur
le terrain beaucoup moins efficace donc
merci merci franck et merci à tous les
bénévoles
nous épuisons profite moi pour remercier
franck parce que donc on travaille aussi
ensemble il ya beaucoup de collaboration
qui existe à croire you sensations et
puis et tv 68 encore pour ces élections
il ya aussi pas mal de journalistes que
vous voyez sur cette antenne aujourd'hui
sur tv 78 qui sont passés par l'école
franck david frank et d'art sur radio
sensations voilà la boucle est un peu
bouclé au niveau du vivier local on
change de sujet à parler d'un engagement
d'un sportif
pour soutenir les enfants malades avec
vous alexandre oui tu me mettre en avant
ils philippe mariani et trois autres
membres six coups club cyclotourisme de
maurepas qui se sont lancé dans un défi
solidaire du 14 au 18 juin
ils vont parcourir 1400 kilomètres à
vélo donc une diagonale entre entre
brest et menton dans les alpes-maritimes
et tous dans leur parcours de pouvoir
ils vont recueillir des fonds pour aider
à lutter contre les cancers et des
vignes hattrick donc les fonds récoltés
iront au profit du service pédiatrique
de l'hôpital mignot au chesnay en poids
et si tout va bien ils vont mettre
environ - 216 heures pour rejoindre suis
là pour votre père votre personnalité du
mois et puis de mon côté je voulais
mettre en avant le travail de jean-marc
ses moulins il est président du pôle
territorial de coopération économique de
vivre les mureaux il accompagne les
porteurs de projet et grâce à lui va
voir le jour un disquaire en tout cas
une pré configuration de boutiques
elle était ouverte il ya quelques jours
alors là on voit des images de
disquaires du côté de versailles mais
c'est un peu à l'identique là du côté de
des mureaux une boutique éphémère dans
la galerie commerciale auchan et si
public est au rendez vous il y aura
ensuite une implantation plus pérenne en
centre-ville son objectif est à la fois
de surfer et permettent d'avoir cette
boutique de vinyle sur le secteur des
mureaux et permettre aux gens de ne pas
se rendre sur paris on sait l'engouement
autour de c est tout ce côté vintage
mais ça permet aussi de créer de
l'emploi voilà donc le travail de
jean-marc ses moulins on en reparlera
aussi sur notre antenne bientôt à la une
à présent dernière rubrique de cette
émission et bientôt à la une sur
l'antenne de radio sensations les
élections oui je rebondis sur le début
d'émission je ne suis pas très pas très
drôle et très innovant aujourd'hui mais
effectivement ce que le 20 et le 27 juin
on va pouvoir ces élections alors avec
nos moyens aussi un
on en parlait tout à l'heure on pourra
pas être présent sur tous les cantons
dans tout l'est dans tous les qg de
campagne mais on va en tout cas proposé
des flashs pendant ces deux soirées
électorales pour tenir au courant des
escor des taux d'abstention donc dans la
soirée du 20 et 27 juin dès les
dimanches
et puis aussi en partenariat avec voo tv
78 puisque on va sur les réseaux sociaux
reprendre de nombreuses nombreuses
publications qui seront qui sont les
vôtres et on va essayer de coopérer un
maximum mais donc on donne rendez vous
aux gens les 20 et 27 juin sur l'antenne
pour qu'ils suivent un peu ces deux
soirées électorales avec des flashs
régulier tout au long de la soirée pour
poursuivre les tendances et les
résultats définitifs très tard dans la
dans la soirée à suivre donc sur
l'antenne de radio sensations 98,4 et
puis sur les réseaux sociaux aussi au
soutien de radio sensations que tv 78
sur tv soixante dix huit rendez vous
pour des éditions spéciales le lendemain
des à 19 heures et ce sont les
journalistes de nos deux rédactions qui
vont travailler conjointement bientôt à
la une sur l'antenne de radio marmite
88,4 les 150 ans de la commune de paris
effectivement wilfried événement
important et qui est célébrée dans une
ville à tradition communiste ou très à
gauche notamment voilà les maires qu'on
a eu comme robert gravaud ou bernard
hinault encore donc voilà il ya des
événements qui sont organisées sur la
ville de trappes et voilà donc marmite
va couvrir ces événements
et voilà faire un petit peu découvrir
cette histoire de la commune de paris
cap a duré longtemps je crois que c'est
71 72 jours voilà suite au conflit
franco prusse voilà pour les souvenirs
d'histoire de l'école on continue à
faire le tour d'horizon de vos médias
locaux et les sujets prochainement
abordé m'a parlé de sport vous êtes très
sport cette semaine ce mois-ci et
alexandre oui c'est vrai avec le plaisir
rugby club qui va entrer dans une
nouvelle ère de son développement à
partir de la rentrée de septembre le
club va ouvrir une sa propre académie de
rugby ça sera en fait un centre
d'entraînement mixte qui sera destiné
aux joueurs et joueuses âgés de
de 16 à 23 ans dans le but de les former
au sport de haut niveau
donc j'ai un stand qui pourra accueillir
45 jeunes tout au long de l'année et à
terme cette structure va permettre au
club en fait d'avoir une base solide de
jeunes pour alimenter son équipe
première et à terme l'objectif c'est de
gravir les échelons pour le club et de
monter d'abord en fédérale une
actuellement ils sont en fédérale 2
depuis quatre ans et donc de monter en
fédérale eut donc c'est l'équivalent de
la troisième division
donc d'ici 2027 et puis après gravir un
échelon supérieur est montée en pro d2
donc celle ci 2032 donc la pro d2 c'est
la division 2 et s'ils y arrivent
plaisir deviendrai le premier club
professionnel de rugby dans les yvelines
et l'historique on n'en est pas là il ya
des objectifs très ambitieux qui vont
demander beaucoup de travail et aussi
beaucoup d'argent et car budget qui va
sensiblement les détails sur le site 7,8
actus.fr également à lire dans les
nouvelles j'en profite pour vous montrer
elle est une des nouvelles les deux
éditions yvelinoise versailles
rambouillet voilà la vidéo à la
vidéo-verbalisation du côté de
versailles est activée et puis l'autre
une c'est celle du côté de rambouillet
les enjeux agricoles de la région ont
parlé de sport et puis se confrontent
allez-y à béjaïa j'ai voulu parler de
sport moi aussi puisque on oublie
peut-être mais ça va être ce mettre en
lien avec la deuxième phase du
déconfinement mais il ya le championnat
d'europe qui commence de football le on
venait d'ailleurs très nationale mais on
oublie très souvent que clairefontaine
et est situé le centre d'entraînement
l'équipe de france est située dans les
yvelines comme quoi fait bien dans
l'avenir et nicolas par contre vous
n'avez pas bien lu le conducteur de
l'émission c à vous est prévu d'en
parler dans quelques minutes
je ne manquerai pas de devenir mettre la
pagaille dans une prochaine émission
jeudi de deux sports et vos contre
sûreté des 78 la journée dédiée aux jeux
olympiques dans trois ans paris à 2024
mettra en valeur également de territoire
yvelinois l'enjeu et fédérer la
population d'ici là à saint quentin en
yvelines le 23 juin journée olympique
qui va regrouper des centaines de jeunes
sera golf national
pour découvrir ce sport mais pas
seulement tous les sports olympiques y
aura des démonstrations des rencontres
s'est ouvert aux écoles
forcément le contexte sanitaire n'aide
pas à ouvrir au grand public il faudra
attendre encore un peu pour ça et tv
fils organisera plusieurs émissions
spéciales rendez vous fin juin donc
notamment points si on parlait sport
avec michael et demi d'euros et
notamment les présidents des différentes
fédérations sportives de france
allez on va parler justement de l'euro
parlons-en vous voulez venir le club de
la presse se termine juste avec l'euro
puisque l'euro de foot débute le 11 juin
et les bleus se préparent donc dans les
yvelines du côté de clairefontaine on
envoie quelques images en général ça
fait l'air beaucoup de monde a
aujourd'hui forcément un petit peu moins
à cause de la situation sanitaire
il va faire vos pronostics nicolas vous
voulez parler de foot pronostics vous en
pensez quoi de cette équipe de france je
pense clairement que si si l'équipe de
france gagne pas l'euro de football ça
se sera vu comme un échec parce qu'ils
ont aujourd'hui je pense la meilleure
équipe ils sont champions du monde en
titre vice champion d'europe aussi en
titre tout autre résultat même si on n'a
pas l'habitude l'inde est très ambitieux
je pense à être l'équipe de france
généralement un peu prudent je pense que
là il faut assumer ce statut de favorite
et et s'il gagne cette compétition en
assumant ce statut de favori montreront
définitivement qu'ils sont la meilleure
équipe
enfin que l'équipe de france est la
meilleure équipe du monde en ce moment
on sait que c'est dur ça va
le statut de favori à penser à 2002 ça
réussit pas du tout du tout du tout la
réalité milliards soit pas celle de
demain
et puisque ça c'est beau est ce que
ferait qu'avec tout ce qui se dit
actuellement wilfried avec le retour de
m on a une équipe géniale vous avez vu
cette attaque de feu toute l'europe a
peur de nous et patati et patata
oui c'est vrai que là ça tous les
ingrédients du scénario catastrophe
n'est tout de même pas sortir des poules
mais bon voilà j'espère qu'on va gagner
est-ce que les pronostics et pas très
positif nous annoncer mon pronostic est
positif le bois j'ai peur quand
j'entends dire que la mariée était trop
belle
en général ce film c'est près de
comparaison très élevée pour part du oui
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que pour
relativiser un peu pour être prudents et
que oui la france est favorite mais un
neurone football est beaucoup plus
relevé qu'à une coupe du monde avec un
niveau beaucoup beaucoup plus dur et on
a un premier tour très très dur avec le
portugal champion d'europe l'allemagne
précédemment championne du monde et ça
peut très mal si vous piller des
premiers matches si vous perdez en
allemagne à munich et vous pouvez très
bien passée à la trappe dès le premier
tour
je vous sens très pessimiste du penalty
si on est petit on va s'en sortir en
rendez vous après la compétition on
verra bien qu'ils aient eu raison ou pas
au débit des mairies fera tout ça donc
on est justement un mot pour engager
vous un petit peu qui sera champion
d'europe et on débriefera ça au mois de
juillet sur le dernier club de la presse
nicolas champion la fin du mois la pompe
au au point la france
noureddine
pour moi la france allait les jeux et
alexandre oui ok bon allez moi je vais
m'engager aussi j'ai pas prendre de
risques je pense à la france mais
effectivement je suis parti un peu
l'occasion le pignon de nouradine aussi
un marié est trop belle pour reprendre
votre votre image
merci à vous trois en tout cas d'avoir
participé à ce club de la presse pour ce
mois de juin merci donc aux journalistes
de radio sensations radio marmite 7,8
actuel et est nouvelle
on se retrouve bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]